thank you so we're going to go ahead and
get started thank you all for being here
it's great to see so many faces my name
is Sameer jaywant I'm a first year
student at the law school and I'm one of
the academic associates that helped to
organize the symposium today we're very
excited to host mr. Zhang chai here to
give the keynote address for this
symposium mr. Chou will speak for about
15 to 20 minutes and then that will be
followed by a Q&A session with the
audience so today's symposium was
entitled does Quebec need a written
constitution and it brought together
scholars from around the US and Canada
to discuss the political and legal
complexities around the question of
whether Quebec can or should have its
own written constitution now the
symposium today was organized and
convened by Professor Richard Albert
professor Albert is an associate
professor of law at Boston College
School of Law and for this academic year
he's been a visiting associate professor
of law and the Canadian bicentennial
visiting professor of political science
here at Yale University professor
Albert's research focuses primarily on
constitutional change and constitutional
amendment and examines that from a
variety of legal perspectives he's
written extensively about Canadian law
and Canadian constitutional law and a
fellow a native Canadian and and wat
Yale Law School alum professor Albert
clerked for the Chief Justice of Canada
Beverly McLaughlin before beginning his
career in academia and so I would just
say that this whole symposium was his
brainchild and you know would not have
come together were it not for him so I'm
thrilled to introduce professor Richard
Albert
[Applause]
one of the great joys of teaching here
at Yale University is the opportunity to
work alongside so many wonderful people
from staff to faculty and to students it
really is a very special community and I
think that sameer represents the very
best of Yale a brilliant student an
advocate for social progress and an
engaged citizen in our campus life and I
have to say that I'm humbled as this
professor because in his presence I'm
often reminded of how little I know and
how much I still have yet to learn so
thank you sameer for that introduction
it's an honor for me and a pleasure to
be here to introduce our keynote speaker
John Shaw a his visit to Yale has been a
long time coming and I'll tell you why
in just a moment but first I want to
thank the McMillan center for
international area studies at Yale for
supporting this program I want to
recognize the research support program
on intergovernmental affairs and Quebec
identity a Quebec US university grant
program and also the Howard orlimar
Center for the Study of frontiers and
borders here at Yale I want to thank all
of them they've been very supportive
generous in showing that Canada matters
here at Yale they care about Canada care
about Canadian Studies and it's it's a
pleasure to be associated with them I
want to thank a number of individuals in
addition to the institutions that I've
recognized I want to recognize Patrick
Beau and Leonid syrota who have worked
with me from the beginning to conceive
this program so thank you to Leonid and
Patrick I want to thank Maddy and
Bernard and Jose belljo Hall for being
with me from the very beginning to help
think through how to put this program
together to a number of individuals
Rehema Chowdhury lina chen lourdes
Haines Marilyn Wilkes in Shapiro George
Joseph for supporting Canadian Studies
here at Yale and also to David Cameron
and Jake inland who are in the Canadian
Studies committee here at Yale for
championing Canadian Studies here at the
University
and finally I want to recognize the
presidents of medical conquer Quebec
delegate to New England for being here
with us today thank you very much for
your presence it's a lovely to have you
with us today all day today across the
street at loose Hall leading scholars in
law and political science have been
gathered for a conference to debate a
provocative and important question does
Quebec need a written constitution a
master text codified Constitution
invited scholars have explored the idea
of a Quebec Constitution within a
Canadian constitutional framework we
have approached the question from
doctrinal from historical from
theoretical perspectives and we've also
looked around the world to other
Federation's where provinces states and
lendor have given themselves written
constitutions within a larger federal
system so we've covered a lot of ground
today on the question of a constitution
for Quebec our keynote speaker for today
we'll both clarify and I think also
complicate our understanding of the
stakes involved in whether Quebec does
in fact need a written constitution as
the 29th Premier of Quebec from 2003 to
2012
jajaja and his cabinet considered the
question the possibility of giving
Quebec a written constitution so who
better to speak to the question we've
explored today as a matter of political
and legal theory than someone who has
devoted considerable time and resources
to evaluating whether it is in fact a
viable idea Shasha beya lawyer elected
to the House of Commons at age 26
becoming the youngest federal cabinet
minister in Canadian history reelected
three times later named Deputy Prime
Minister of Canada an amazing record of
service I'm sure you'll agree to Canada
but I think he would say that what
brings him pride above all else is that
he is son of claude and rita husband to
michele and father of emily Ottawa and
Alexandra
almost twenty years ago in 1997 I was
here at Yale as a student finishing my
freshman year and I returned home to
Canada that summer to Orleans where I
was raised and at that time John shahe
was leading his federal political party
into an election
I had begun following joshua ever very
closely a few years earlier when he had
successfully rallied support behind
canada and against the threat of quebec
secession from the country in the 1995
referendum a loyal in tireless
Federalist he had served then as the
vice chair of the National Committee of
Quebecers against the session and many
in fact credit him among a handful of
very important political leaders at the
time for helping to keep Quebec within
Canada and so in 1997 when I returned
home to Canada I campaigned for him and
his team over the next couple of years
when I came back to Yale to complete my
studies we tried to get him to join us
on campus for a visit we came very close
very very close but the timing was
difficult because by then he had left
federal politics to come back home to
lead the Quebec Liberal Party in the
National Assembly to continue the fight
as it were on the front lines for a
strong Quebec within a united Canada
soon thereafter he was elected Premier
of Quebec his home province and also
mine and he was later reelected twice
serving from 2003 to 2012 a tenure of
service marked by accomplishments in
economic growth and diversification
environmental protection and gender
equality among a number of others two
years ago I once again ran into Jean
Shara but this time it was at the
Calgary Stampede he was almost
unrecognizable in his cowboy hat and
boots almost unrecognizable and there we
spoke and we planted the seed for this
program today and so here we are today
with Joshua finally at Yale a few years
later than I had hoped
about 19 years later than I had hoped
here nonetheless proving to me and now
also to you that all good things do
indeed come to those who wait so Josh
Etta we welcome you to Yale University
we look forward to your remarks today
[Applause]
thank you Richard that was a very kind
introduction and the Calgary Stampede
part in particular for those of us who
know about Alberta in the West I do want
to acknowledge the presence of medical
Takao who I had the pleasure of working
with for a number of years in my
government and was delighted when she
accepted the position of the division at
alg Quebec in Boston and had a short
period of time off and then returned to
this job so thank you very much for
being with us
and Ted Morton also had the pleasure of
working with Ted mentioned in his
presentation a little earlier across the
street that he had worked very closely
with Mo bhishan which I remember very
well and about the relationship between
Alberta and Quebec that we can talk
about today which i think is a very
important part of what makes up the
dynamic in the in the Canadian
Federation so and before I start my
remarks today I want to thank two people
who have helped me prepare them because
there is always a lot of work to do
there's Francois called Bay who's with
me today who's a an articling I
shouldn't say student with me he's doing
a master's degree at Sherbrooke
University in international law on
politics and has been working with me
he's also a lawyer and so he's done a
lot of work in preparing notes for today
as my son Antoine that you mentioned a
little earlier who did a masters at LSC
and is very interested in political
philosophy and and is now doing a
doctorate at the University of Montreal
I'm very interested in the issues
relation in relation to identity and the
work of Charles Taylor and a share an
anecdote about Antoine he was very
active in the Youth Commission of the
Liberal Party of Quebec so those of you
are familiar with Quebec politics
well no it's it's a very very dynamic
youth group and a lot of the leaders who
are in the assembly come up through that
Youth Commission
and so one day as I'm premier I walk out
the door at home and I'm handed the
newspaper with a front-page story saying
that I'm denounced by my youth
Commission on the issue of
multiculturalism that the the premier
doesn't understand that we should be
applying interculturalism as a concept
and it goes on and I have a few media
events that day I get plummeted by the
media that day because the Youth
Commission is opposed to the leader and
so I returned home that night at dinner
my son is there and I'm frustrated I say
to him did you see what your group did
today did you see the paper he said yes
I did I wrote the paper he was the
author of this and he told me he said
you never understood this issue anyway
and I was so it does give you a sense of
the discussions we have at home I
accepted your invitation in part because
not only was it a something that I
wanted to do 19 years later but also the
context is of an interesting context
where there's not a lot of discussion
about constitutional issues today in
Quebec or in Canada there's a reason for
that there's a context around that but
also there's a more recent event that
that gave me a lot of cause for concern
and that was when the Parti québécois
was in power and Matt I'm Matt Webb
brought forward this idea of a Charter
of Rights and I've chartered and shout
of identity charter very controversial
and something that frankly I found to be
offensive for only if only for one
reason it was one of the first I think
it was the first time that I witnessed
the separatist movement in Quebec
deliberately devised a policy with the
view of opposing one group against the
other
now the separatist movement in Quebec
and I'm not saying they have a monopoly
on on this neither do the separate that
Federalists had from time to time would
do things say statements that would be
very divisive as Jacques Parizeau did on
the night of the referendum campaign
when they lost statement from which he
never recanted by the way he never
apologized he never said I was wrong
and I should not have said it and that
left a very profound mark on a number of
Quebecers
but when madam Matt West charter of
values was proposed with a view of
dividing people one of the questions
that came to mind was could this happen
had there been a Quebec charter of
Quebec Constitution or how would this
charter for example be tested against
the Quebec Bill of Rights that blessa
brought in in 1974 and so the question
of the implementation the respective
rights how they're enunciated how we use
them was asked in that context and and
it's one of the reasons why I thought
this discussion is is important and
certainly interesting my political
career as you know has all have been has
been about Canada and about Quebec
within Canada the common thread of
everything I've done over the years has
been in reference to fighting for the
ideal of Canada and the fact that Quebec
should be part of it and in fact without
Quebec Canada as a country I'm not sure
would survive that being said I want to
start by by saying that I was also very
involved early in my career on these
issues when I was named a cabinet in
1986 at 28 years old I was also named to
the Cabinet Committee on preparing the
Meech Lake negotiations that were not
known as Meech Lake at the time all we
knew was that as an addict cabinet
committee our job and it was chaired by
Lowell Murray at the time who was the
minister of intergovernmental affairs
was to prepare the groundwork for a
meeting that would be held between the
Prime Minister of Canada and the
Premier's on the issue of our
constitutional future and the
integration of of Quebec and so that was
my first job at at this issue in a
formal way it was followed by two other
important episodes I wanted to speak to
today one was chairing the special House
of Commons Committee on the companion
resolutions to the Meech Lake Accord
that were delivered in the spring of
1990 with a view of trying to fix the
Meech Lake Accord to make it acceptable
to those who had objections a very very
intense period in the life of the
country and the third episode for me
after that was 1998 of course there was
a Charlottetown Accord I campaigned for
but 1998 and in 1998 I campaigned as a
leader of the Liberal Party of Quebec
and the issue in that campaign in the
end the issue we made in the ad was no
referendum I remember it very well
because the campaign was not going well
at all and new Shambhu Sharan in 1998
was very straightforward he would win a
new majority government and hold another
referendum and he was very powerful and
charismatic and the chances of him
winning that referendum were very very
high well we dedicated the whole last
chapter of our election campaign
fighting that idea and turned it into
two new words no referendum on the night
of the election you see in Peshawar won
a plura the majority of the seats we won
a plurality of the votes and you see
admits to this today that his project of
holding another referendum disappeared
on that evening I tell that story to
those who I speak to sometimes about
politics when I want to refer to an
example when a defeat is indicated
sometimes more important than victory of
all the election campaigns I was
involved in the 98 campaign was the most
important one not the one I won the one
I lost but having lost it lost that
campaign that way it allowed the country
breathing space to go on and fight
another day so I've had a chance over
the years to think about these issues
and to explore the idea of a Quebec
referendum we when I became leader of
the Liberal Party of Quebec in 1998 with
Benoit Patsy that was referred to this
morning was an extraordinarily competent
minister of intergovernmental affairs
and an expert on constitutional law
teaches at Ottawa University we put
together a special working group within
the Liberal Party of Quebec
to prepare what our position would be on
intergovernmental relations large and
one of the orientations that we proposed
coming out of that working group was
that Quebec would work at developing and
further developing its relationship not
only with Ottawa but also with the rest
of the country one of the things that we
believed and continue to believe I
continue to believe is underutilized and
under explored and is the relationship
between the provinces and not just
Quebec versus Ottawa from that paper
came the idea the creation of the
Council of the Federation of the Santa
franca front of the Francophonie de
Semitic that was since created the
recognition of asymmetrical federalism
in chitara and so in that particular
paper and that committee chaired by ban
weapons he were born these these ideas I
want to return to the the period of
Meech Lake though and one of the great
lessons of Meech Lake itself and there
are a few things that emerged from that
episode that I thought were worth
returning to one of them is an important
misunderstanding that emerged from the
goal of Meech Lake the goal from the
perspective of the federal government
than the government of Quebec was to
complete the repatriation of our
Constitution by allowing Quebec to sign
it not to bring more fundamental changes
to the constitution of Canada not a
redistribution of power but rather to
complete the process that had not been
completed in 1982 now the other the
other thing that I drew from the
experience of nineteen of this
1990 process 1987 290 was the fact that
the strategy of implementation of the
Meech Lake Accord was also defective
there was the alignment between the
strategy to implement and the content
had not been thought through why well I
think because the leaders of the time
assumed a number of things that ended up
being wrong
one of them was that the process should
take three years when in fact had they
known what they were getting into they
would have moved much more expedia to
get the work done why because the
three-year period allowed opponents to
organize and to mobilize public opinion
against the Accord the reason why I
raise this is because any work done in
regards to constitutional change if we
draw from that experience requires that
there be an alignment between the
amendment in the act content and
implementation in fact if I had to give
advice to those who are thinking of
amending or doing constitutional work I
would start by telling them tell me
first before you even get into the
discussion on what it is you want to
change on how it is you are going to
change it and if you cannot give me a
clear path that leads us to
implementation then I would recommend
that you not especially not deal with
this issue keeping in mind that when you
deal with the constitution of a country
it's like dealing or changing the
foundations of a house of a building
it's not like changing a wall in a room
which would be similar to typical
standard legislation a constitution is
the bedrock the foundation of the
country it speaks not only to the law
and the fundamental law but it also
speaks to something that you referred to
earlier in your discussions today in
regards to identity and who we are now
let me say a word about Canada
I things you already know but I want to
repeat because it is it very relevant to
anything that has to do with the
constitutional discussion in Canada
whether provincial constitutions or
otherwise we are in Canada one of the
most decentralized Federation's in the
world a lot of work has been done about
this but the work I saw is very much on
the ground I remember doing a press
conference with actual mas who until
very recently was the president of
Catalonia who I met several times and in
the privacy of his office said to me
Jean if I had the powers that Quebec had
I take that today that deal I would
accept it today and we would be
perfectly happy and I thought to myself
that's great he says that to me in the
privacy of his office and then we held a
press conference and he repeated the
same thing publicly if you go to
Scotland for example and look at the
devolution of powers that the Blair
government gave to the government of
Scotland there is no comparison in
regards to the powers that we have in
Quebec if you go to Australia for
example same thing in terms of fiscal
power in particular and the United
States I would venture to say the
Canadian provinces have much more power
than any other Federation I know except
probably Belgium whose system of federal
government no one understands anyway
Bell Nalanda Diaz Premier of Quebec once
made a very surprising statement he said
Quebec had more powers than most
sovereign countries most sovereign
countries and when you look at there are
fiscal or constitutional framework in
Canada how does it how does it work
essentially I'm going to simplify here
and I was talking about this earlier
with Professor Wiseman but essentially
in Canada it's the provinces who run the
country education health care the roads
civil law the provinces run the country
on a day to day basis we make it work
the federal government is like a holding
they transfer money if you want to
measure it go and look at the last
federal budget look at the percentage of
money dedicated to operating the
Government of Canada including salaries
I don't I'm guessing it may not be
higher than 20% and the government of
Quebec alone 60% of the budget is
dedicated to salaries only salary 60%
it's the governments of the provinces
that run the country the federal
government transfers money they run
federal penitentiary z-- they run they
responsible for First Nations for which
they're we all agree they're doing a
fantastic job they are in charge of part
of foreign policy but not exclusively
Metis code is evidence of that
the Bank of Canada but what the federal
government has in particular
the real power it has that's significant
is spending power money that's at the
end of the day whether it's the power of
reserve or dick at the end of the day
where the Government of Canada is
significant is in its ability to raise
taxes and spend money and to tie
conditions to what they they do Canada
also is a country that is founded by the
French the English and First Nations
multi-ethnic multinational list however
you want to call it as a federation that
also distinguishes who we are and the
vast territory that we occupy and the
fact that we have a small population
base is relevant to who we are also so
you have to take our constitutional
discussions in that context one of the
things I wanted to also speak to and it
was raised in the part of the
discussions I witness is that context is
everything in this discussion of course
it is yes the word Constitution doesn't
resonate or mean the same thing in one
environment than it does in another
and in Canada it is not transactional if
Danielle surprises in the National
Assembly of Quebec and proposes a
constitution for Quebec there is no
doubt in anyone's mind that for him this
is the antechamber of separating Quebec
from Canada and they will even say to
the Federalists as they have said well
you know this is done within the
Canadian framework what are you worried
about but what they are really trying to
accomplish from our perspective is
create forward momentum that will allows
them to advance the discussion and I'll
give you an idea of how it connects to
process in 2016 is there anyone who
thinks that Quebec could adopt a
constitution and not hold a referendum
well I don't think it's possible I think
the only way you could adopt a
constitution in Quebec is hold a
referendum well guess what what will
Danielle Terps say then he'll say it
it's perfect referendums about choice we
have to give them a choice if you're
only offering the constitution then it's
not a real choice really is it you have
to offer separation or the Constitution
now put yourself in my shoes to speak of
the real politics of a Quebec
Constitution for 30 years I have fought
tooth and nail for the ideal of Canada
and Quebec within Canada and I have been
a wartime General in referendums 95 and
92 and the 98 campaign and I have
campaigned saying to Quebecers no
referendum realistically if I were
premier Quebec and I proposed a
constitution and said the Quebecers were
going to have a referendum could you
blame them for being confused do you
think that I could overcome that
confusion with a public-opinion who for
the last 30 years has heard me say no
referendum
can I win that battle that would be one
of the first questions I would have to
ask myself and I think most of you
probably have an idea whether or not I
could win that battle
now that ladies and gentlemen is quite
separate from the idea of whether or not
a constitution in itself would be good
or bad frankly on many matters there are
very solid rational arguments to be made
on having a good written provincial
constitution back to my time at wasp loi
and the separatist ploy to invoke and by
the way they very deliberately knowing
for example that their Charter would be
disallowed by the courts which would
then create an environment or a
flashpoint that would feed resentment
against the federal government leading
to a referendum that's how clear it was
they deliberately did something that
legislators are never supposed to do is
vote laws that you know to be contrary
to the rule of law in your country for
the purpose of creating a political
debate that you hope you can win had we
had maybe a written constitution that
brought under one single umbrella
different laws that have been mentioned
I suppose this morning whether it's art
Quebec Chablis desi DBT unit and the
French language of Charter of Rights
that French Charter and/or electoral law
and other pieces of legislation we may
have been able to prevent that or make a
stronger case against it or create a
public environment that would have been
more hostile and more easy to mobilize
against such a blatant use of our laws
for the purpose of advancing the cause
of separation
maybe the other argument you could make
is that if a Quebec had its own written
constitution it would allow Quebecers to
reinforce and further secure their sense
of identity which will always be an
issue
Quebecers sometimes see themselves as a
majority within Quebec which they are
and other times as a minority within
Canada and a minority within North
America any government of Quebec any
Premier of Quebec is is tasked with the
mission to protect our language and
culture it is a sacred mission that is
invested in every single Premier of
Quebec so that they can allow this
unique language and culture to continue
to thrive within North America and the
world and so in that respect maybe a
Quebec Constitution could be helpful
could reinforce that sense of identity
which is an integral integral part of
any Constitution making as we learn from
the distinct Society clause in the Meech
debate there was a revelation moment for
me when I was chair of the committee and
four members of the committee when
Charles Taylor testified in front of our
committee and explained to the members
of the committee why the distinct
Society Clause was so important to
Quebecers and he said something in words
we had never heard before but were so
simple to understand he said to us today
for Quebecers the distinct society
Clause is a bridge between their
identity as being both a Quebec er and
the Canadian it is a bridge if you blow
up that bridge you weaken that
relationship he presented it to us the
best and so when the debate evolved on
Meech Lake in that period and that's the
same for any constitutional I would say
debate in Canada and outside of Quebec
the debate focused on technical
issues legal issues some relevant some
not and in Quebec it was an issue of
identity identity that you should
interpret as synonymous to respect
recognition what is identity about for
any given group two words recognition
and respect am i recognized am i
respected for who I am by the way there
are very real similarities in that
dynamic with what is happening today
with First Nations in Canada the quest
and their thirst for recognition and
respect which is part of what any
minority seeks to feel at home and able
to thrive and so if a Quebec
Constitution were ever contemplated this
could be if the circumstances were right
one of the positive outcomes of drafting
such a document but I want to return to
what I was saying a little earlier the
circumstances would have to exist for
that discussion to happen will it happen
all of us who care about the future of
Canada hope that it will one day happen
that there will be a moment or
circumstances in which governments in
Canada can lead on this issue and say we
need to fix our constitution of 82 that
may be drafting provincial constitutions
as part of it you could envisage a
scenario for example where the rest of
the country after Quebec would have
drafted its own written constitution
would embrace that Constitution as
opposed to saying we're going to
recognize this or that say I will
recognize what you have drafted you
could do it through section maybe
forty-three or otherwise you know more
about the technical part of that than I
do but I don't see that day on horizon
right now what I do know is this which
you haven't talked a lot about today is
that the federal system of government
whether it's in Canada or elsewhere
isn't only about the Constitution a
healthy vigorous federal system of
government evolves outside of its
constitutional framework and our view
and why we were in government my view
was that we should do everything in our
power to allow that federal system to
evolve in respect of the interest of
Quebec and Canada and if one day we are
in a position to negotiate a new
agreement then we will have set the
table to do that so what did we do we
created the Council of Federation we
negotiated an agreement within with the
federal government on UNESCO the
participation of Quebec within UNESCO
and within the framework of the rules of
UNESCO when as far as we could to
recognize Quebec as being part of that
delegation in 2004 we negotiated a
healthcare agreement and one of the
conditions of signing the agreement from
the perspective of Quebec was total
respect of our autonomy and spending the
money that was transferred
unconditionally a and B the recognition
of the principle of asymmetric
federalism that was formally put into
the agreement and signed by every single
premier who attended that conference
including the Prime Minister of Canada
during our mandate the Federal
Government of Canada recognized through
a motion in the House of Commons that
Quebec was a nation within Canada during
our mandate for the first time ever the
federal government accepted it had
forced partly forced upon it the
presence of provincial governments at
the table to negotiate a major trade
agreement the Canada the acetic
the most advanced trade agreement in the
world and by the way because the
Europeans knew about our federal system
of government they said to the federal
government we will only negotiate if the
provinces are at the table if they're
not at the table we will not negotiate
with you the federal government of the
time said to them well it's complicated
you know stuff so why well you know
there's 10 provinces and 3 territories
and you know they all have their and
you're being said to them you know what
we have 27 sovereign nations we can do
it and you can well the outcome is one
of the most not one of the most the most
advanced trade agreement in the world
but put yourself in the shoes of Europe
why would they negotiate a grade B trade
agreement with Canada when it's the most
decentralized Federation in the world
and the issues you want to address our
issues like government procurement that
happen within the competencies of the
provinces not the federal government
these are all the things that we were
able to accomplish outside of a
constitutional framework and that allows
Canada to function more effectively as a
country and so today as you see I'm not
giving you the answer yes or no answer
that you're looking for certainly we can
anticipate the day where this will
happen but as things stand now I if I
had to give advice to a government of
Quebec I would say maybe if the
circumstances are right and if there is
an alignment of process with content and
leadership that speaks to how this will
be done but until that day appears I
would I would recommend that we continue
to work with what we have thank you
so now we'll start the Q&A portion just
raise your hand and I'll come and give
you the mic don't be shy
thank you I think everybody in the room
understands the risk of kind of opening
the Pandora's box the mini there's a
referendum on anything in Quebec and at
the risk outweigh the benefits I think
you probably receptive audience here but
you heard the kind of the modest mini
package I talked about in the last panel
this afternoon is that is that small
enough minimal enough incremental enough
to look at in the next year or two in
Quebec without running the risk of the
lid of the Pandora's box on identity
politics coming out again and Ted if I
were Alberta I would prepare a scenario
and if I were the premier of Alberta I
would be I would say to my officials
prepare scenarios that would allow us to
defend our interest within the Canadian
framework which isn't contrary to
Canada's interest and that would would
allow us to to advance I do like there's
a you know there's different approaches
possible there can be a minimalist
approach that is not led by Quebec but
led by someone outside of Quebec because
after Meech Lake people concluded that
if it were again a Quebec led initiative
that would contaminate the the the
process and maybe if it came elsewhere
I'm guessing I can only guess you know
what I think it'll probably though if we
have another round it'll probably happen
by accident partly by accident something
will break something a ruling will
happen and something will force the hand
of those who are involved Senate reform
could have been that an interesting at
the leaders are interesting by our share
an anecdote with you I met with Stephen
Harper several times when he was Prime
Minister on Senate reform we talked
about it
and I'm not delivering any great secret
here I said to the Prime Minister
several times I don't know why you keep
talking about Senate reform you are
proposing things that are not going to
happen in the last federal campaign in
Canada with it it was very interesting
federal leaders going out there and
saying we are going to abolish the
Senate we're going to abolish the Senate
and our media so weak no one calling we
have a recently I mean the ink isn't dry
on the Supreme Court ruling that says
you can't do that it is not allowed and
all this ruling by the way is based on a
1979 Supreme Court Rule I'm saying that
I'm remember saying Prime Minister
Harper at the time I I don't know why
you keep creating this expectation we
are going to bring you to court I'm
telling you now if you do that we're
bringing you to court and we'll win and
we did bring him to court and we won as
we did with you on the national
regulators and I we told them that was
saying the same thing you are going to
run into a brick wall
but sometimes the politics of it gets
out of control and so back to your
question if that were to happen I'm not
sure in what circumstances that window
will open but if I were in Alberta or
elsewhere in the world I'd like to have
people that I could turn to who have
given some thought on how that would and
I'll finish where I started my remarks
though I would not trust anyone to go
ahead with a process or a proposal if at
first they couldn't tell me how are you
going to get this done and there's one
person in Canada and one province in
Canada that implemented successfully an
amendment of this nature and who we can
draw a lesson from and if you ask me the
question I'll tell you who it is maybe
okay I'll tell you right away remember
Brian Tobin's amendment on his
confessional law schools he proposed it
and held the referendum 30 days after
Dave lien bang the opposition never had
a chance
now I'm not saying it's the example to
follow what I'm saying in this specific
case of Tobin is that he had a very
clear idea of how he was going to
implement it and how he would proceed
and if you don't have that then I don't
think you should anyone should be
playing yes yeah I'm not sure he won he
won well Mr Weisman I'll have to my
recollection that is one they need to
hold two referendums how could he hold
two referendums within the same mandate
of a parliament on the same issue that's
not allowed
okay maybe someone knows the answer to
that question here you talked about the
Scottish referendum we you know with
Canadians were widely consulted on that
it was fascinating to see how they
followed the same and on the Scottish
side how it's the same I would go to
meetings by the way in see Alex Salmond
he would run across the aisle you know
not talk to me and but it was the same
these referendums are based on emotion
it's never based on reason and if that
isn't fueling the referendum that's why
the separatists are so mr. Terp and
others are I think so determined to push
an agenda like this and that's that is
their agenda which we have to separate
from the basic merits of whether or not
there should be a constitutional written
a written constitution
well thank you are there any other
questions otherwise all you've had a
long day thank you very very much and we
hope to see you in Quebec I'll finish
with one nanak small anecdote on the
nation and how it happened
mr. harper came to quebec in on the 24th
of june 2006
hold a cabinet meeting he'd just been
elected thought this was a great idea
nada Barclay was a leader of the tots
Kubica at the time and he challenged mr.
Harbor he said to him since you're in
Quebec City and you want to be you know
why don't you recognize Quebec as a
nation do it now I met with mr. Harper
that evening and on that evening I
quoted I gave him my favorite quote of
Sir John a McDonald sir Johnny MacDonald
wrote to a journalist of the Montreal
Gazette in 1860 I think was 1864
answering the question of why did you
accept the federal pact as opposed to a
more unitary system of government and
talking about Quebecers he was talking
about French Canadians he said treat
them as a nation that's the word he
chose treat them as a nation and they
will behave as a people of a nation do
in a generous treat them as a faction
and they will behave fatuously I'm
paraphrasing but that is the most
important quote I know of sir Johnny
McDonald and I said the Steven Harper on
that evening I said if the first of
prime minister of our country was able
to recognize Quebec as being a nation
why would you want to contradict him
today and and I think sir Johnny was
right so thank you very much
you
[Music]